let's talk about the real cause and cure
for your dandruff I'm going to talk
about what it is the current treatment
for it
and what's really behind dandruff as
well as a really good solution how about
that what is dandruff very simply it's
scaly flaky scalp okay you have the
layers of skin
in the scalp that are flaking off
prematurely normally there's about a
month cycle where the skin cells in your
scalp develop and then Slough off with
dandruff they're sloughing off
every week okay it's seven days instead
of a whole month okay so we'll talk
about why that is but very simply if you
ask anyone what dandruff is
um they'll probably show you these
little flaking skin cells on their
shoulders and this is why the number one
treatment for it is Head and Shoulders
which they're using a certain chemical
zinc peridathione
zpt
which is an anti-fungal okay and it's
also antibacterial so it'll kill
microbes in your scalp and it does get
rid of dandruff at least temporarily now
the problem with this treatment is that
it's banned in Europe because apparently
it does cause some toxicity to be
reproductive organs okay like all
chemicals and medications there's always
different side effects there is a
certain fungus that the isolated being
behind this whole problem and that
microbe is called malassezia it is a
fungus that has gone Rogue all right
it's part of our normal flora that we
have on our skin and it's really the
overgrowth and how this fungus morphs
into a kind of a pathogenic microbe when
the condition or environment changes
okay like all microbes they live in
communities and there's a lot of
different diversification of microbes
that are inside our body and on our skin
and when we have this imbalance we get
um certain microbes that change their
form and they do weird things and they
also cause our own immune system to
react with certain defenses and there's
inflammation that occurs and collateral
damage so at the very root of dandruff
there's really an imbalance in the
microflora on your scalp where we have a
kind of a morphed fungus that is no
longer friendly so it's creating an
immune reaction and what people don't
realize is that you have not just
friendly bacteria you have friendly
yeast you have friendly fungus on your
body and inside that is helping you okay
just like the soil you don't just have
friendly bacteria you also have friendly
yeast and fungus that without that yeast
or fungus the plants can't dig their
roots and absorb the nutrients as well
so the fungus is just as important as
the bacteria in doing its job without
the fungus in the soil they can't uh
dissolve the minerals to really pull it
in and allow the roots to absorb it into
the plant and apparently this fungus
that grows on your scalp
eats lipids okay it eats fats it eats
the sebum which is the oil that comes
from the oil glands around the follicles
around your hair follicles but what's
interesting about this fungus is
it doesn't like all the fats okay it
only likes the saturated fats it likes
to eat triglycerides it doesn't like to
eat the omega-6 fatty acids and that's
very interesting because the omega-6
fatty acids are the inflammatory acids
so personally
I would need the omega-6 I would
definitely at the saturated fats but not
the omega-6 because these are the
inflammatory type fats which has been
linked to inflammation which is exactly
what's happening on your scalp is just
the tip of the iceberg and what's really
going on it's happening in your gut
Flora now obviously if you affect the
gut you affect the skin you affect a lot
of other things but an isolated symptom
of dandruff on your scalp there's
probably a lot of other things going on
for example there's a huge correlation
between people developing dandruff and
just after they had some type of
antibiotic right so you're taking this
antibiotic internally it's killing off
your microflora and your gut and then
you're ending up with a systemic problem
on your skin the same thing happens when
you take an antibiotic right you kill
off the bacteria and you end up with a
yeast infection which can happen in your
mouth I mean just because you affect one
part of the body doesn't mean that it
can't be systemic and start invading
other parts of your body
we do know this antibiotic kills only
bacteria it doesn't kill viruses it
doesn't kill fungus or yeast and this is
why it's very important to understand
the microbiome you have a lot of
different types of microbes growing in
your gut and on your skin and you have
to understand that
certain microbes like bacteria keep the
fungus in check keep the yeast in check
and if you wipe out the bacteria then
the yeast and fungus can grow at a very
very high rate what do you think would
be a good solution to dandruff well why
don't we just add the bacteria back in
to the skin okay that sounds pretty good
right and just so you know
um the solutions that I'm coming up with
I found while searching patents for
natural remedies to dandruff which is
actually quite fascinating and I'll put
those links down below I get so much
great data from patents because when
someone puts a patent out they give you
all this amazing research first so it
helps to consolidate a lot of data that
I probably wouldn't find if I'm just
doing searches on Google so the first
remedy that I'm going to recommend and
there's quite a few different things you
can do for dandruff but it is to put
back in the microflora to keep this
fungus in check and I'm going to
recommend you get that micro from kimchi
okay now you're going to be using just
the juice of it the fluid not the actual
you know the Cabbage or anything like
that you get one teaspoon and you mix it
in some water okay and
when you take your shower okay you use
your shampoo whatever
right when you get done you can
topically put this diluted solution into
your scalp you rub it in your scalp and
you wait for 15 minutes you go back into
the shower or the sink and rinse it out
what you're doing is just putting a
probiotic back into your scalp there's a
lot of other things you can do there's
other options okay I'll just tell you a
few two teaspoons of olive oil with a
half a teaspoon of coconut oil which has
lauric acid which is really good as an
anti-fungal you can rub that into your
scalp before you go to bed then you wake
up take a shower and then you can just
clean your hair
but the point is there are other things
other than just putting this probiotic
back into your scalp you can use a
diluted tea tree oil diluted garlic oil
you can use diluted oregano oil there's
so many different things you can use as
a natural
antibiotic without the side effects now
the next thing I'm going to recommend is
to really fix your diet because I really
believe that if you don't fix your diet
the standard probably just going to keep
coming back because it's coming from an
imbalance in your gut and one thing
about yeast or fungus okay or Candida
those microorganisms love sugar they are
carboholics I mean think about
fermentation okay making alcohol vinegar
um yogurt all these fermentation type
processes what are they fermenting
they're fermenting carbohydrates sugar
guess what type of diet you should be on
low carb no sugar diet okay and then of
course
do the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet which is low omega-6 fatty acids so
I would avoid the soy oil the canola the
corn oils which are very inflammatory
there are a lot of people who get on the
ketogenic diet and their dandruff goes
away without even doing anything else so
you should know that I would also start
eating foods that have probiotics
sauerkraut
kimchi
Kiefer
are just a few number three change your
shampoo if you're using your typical
shampoo and a conditioner if you read
the back of the label there's a lot of
different chemicals and a lot of these
chemicals are anti-microbial so it's
very similar into putting insecticides
pesticides herbicides into the soil it's
going to disrupt the microbiome well the
same thing that's going to happen when
you start putting these chemicals on
your hair not to mention some people use
a lot of hairspray they use chemicals
with dyes they use their hair dryer with
high Heats all these things affect the
microbiome of your scalp so if you find
a shampoo and conditioner that's clean
that doesn't have chemicals and if you
wanna a good one I will put a link down
below
but this is just something that people
uh need to be aware of and number four
get a shower filter that filters out at
least chlorine and maybe even fluoride
chlorine in tap water City water and
fluoride are very very irritating to
your microbes on your surface of your
skin and when you get a good shower
filter you may find that your skin not
just on your scalp improves but the rest
of your skin and your face you might
find an improvement in your acne you
might find that just the overall tone of
your skin is much much better now the
next most important video for you to
watch would be the one that I did on
acne okay relating to this topic check
this out I put it up right here